hey friends you're in for a treat today
with our good old friend
dr eric weinstein joining us for a
quarterly update
on life liberty and the pursuit
of getting off this planet we talked a
lot about uh geometric unity and his uh
ideas about the future of physics and
getting off of the planet as i say
and we're going to talk about all sorts
of topics including his concerns fears
and anxiety about the hair
trigger and high stakes activities going
on in geopolitics i hope you'll
subscribe to the channel and leave a
comment thumbs up would you like the
best about this video and also uh what
you'd like to hear us talk about in the
future that'll be a lot of fun to hear
as well make sure you stay tuned as i
say we've got a pulitzer prize winner ed
young coming on the podcast walter
isaacson talking about nobel prize
winner jennifer doudna and his wonderful
book the code breaker and ben franklin
and all sorts of other cool
interviews as well as upcoming
conversations
with uh folks like phil goff and his
claim that everything is conscious pan
psychic
consciousness pervades the universe so i
hope you'll enjoy it stay tuned and
subscribe and now let's go into the
impossible
with the state of the multiverse with
our friend dr eric weinstein let's go
[Music]
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everybody to a quarterly update
with times man of the microsecond no no
this is this is perhaps one of the
greatest of all friends and neighbors it
is eric weinstein joining me today to
speak about the state of the multiverse
eric how are you doing good sir
great brian how are you it's great to
see you i wish we were in person uh
we're gonna have to make that happen
it's been been a month or two it's a
little too long start going through
einstein withdrawal symptoms i get the
shakes
um this is uh being recorded after uh
well it's before the traditional april
fool's holiday that we both solemnly
celebrate every year uh and celebrated
last year with a live episode uh but
this is being recorded afterwards and uh
and i might be mistaken but there might
be some news afoot in your particular
uh area of the multiverse why don't you
share any news that you'd like to share
right up front well i don't know really
that i um
it sounds like i'm supposed to say i'm
pregnant but uh
thank you um
i think i think what's going on with me
is that uh
i'm
trying to understand
why i'm perceiving a different situation
in a different planet
than
the rest of my brethren i'm i feel like
we're being called to do very specific
things we're clearly not doing them
and a lot of this is being driven by the
accident if you will
of um
vladimir putin taking some initiative
in eastern europe
yeah i mean it's amazing we spoke on
christmas eve i think it was last time
uh for the podcast
and
you know at that time i was like ah
maybe things are calming down it seems
like maybe the end of the covet is in
sight that omicron is going to put a
blissful end and maybe things will
settle down but what do you make of this
my father you know of blessed memory
used to go to bed every night listening
to art bell
uh who is a titanic individual in the
world of broadcasting you may know of
him you may not he used to do like a
12-hour radio show and then he'd sign
off at three in the morning and then
he'd go on ham radio
for like another eight this guy was it
was a titan in the field anyway the uh
the point that he would often bring up
is that the pace of humanity is
accelerating not the kurzweil esque
singularity but this sort of quickening
that news cycles that events that
titanic shifts are occurring faster and
faster and ever more so after september
11th of course but i feel like it's
unsustainable i i feel like we cannot
get off uh of this cycle of just in
constant adrenaline hits uh so i was you
know in need of talking to you many
times in the last couple of months and i
know the audience was too but how are we
going to mix i mean is it
where do you see us going let's let's
just not bury the lead are are we headed
towards a
incredibly serious uh nuclear
confrontation with uh with an armed
nearly 70 year old individual with a
nearly 80 year old individual at the
helm of the free world
probably not
but
probably not means less than 50 percent
so
if i actually do the math on this and no
one can because it's not a math problem
but metaphorically if i start to compile
the facts
i would guess that we are running
between one and five percent chance of a
nuclear exchange
over no known ideology
um
before this ukrainian adventure uh
has concluded
and
one thing that i've learned is that if
the odds aren't over 50 a giant
percentage of the population says well
it's unlikely
all right they don't weighted against
what we're talking about so you know for
me i would like to be able to whisper
i don't know maybe it's three percent
maybe it's five percent maybe it's one
percent
we're running some catastrophic risk
of
having the mahabharata
box me b minor mass
all of the
sporting events that have ever been held
with
fantastic outcome bob beeman's long jump
all of that being obliterated
by
the choices of what i take to be five
relatively undistinguished human beings
and that would be putin
biden zielinski ji
and kim in north korea and i'm looking
at these people i mean this is to say
nothing of iran or modi in india but
just just the five people i named are
reevaluating the chess board the world
war ii order has now broken
um the invasion of ukraine by russia
is unprecedented in the 21st century and
it is very well precedented in the 20th
so
the thing that was holding everything
together is now broken
and we're living through something that
is akin to the cuban missile crisis in
my estimation
but until all of the news outlets say
the odds are you know considerably north
of the odds during the cuban missile
crisis no one's going to wake up now why
are the odds so high
it's not capitalism versus communism
it's not
protestants first is first versus you
know
catholics it's not hindus versus uh
muslims it's
we got into a habit during peacetime of
um just deciding that every time we
could expand nato that was a great thing
and depending upon how you think about
that either it's a wonderful strategy
for
um you know really controlling russia by
encircling it with allies of the west
or it's a provocation just the way we
would see it if it was happening in our
hemisphere and somehow china was setting
up a base in toronto or something like
that right although you know to push
back with respect on that
when you look at uh you know our
territorial aspirations it wasn't like
you know we were threatening russia we
weren't uh we meaning ukraine rather it
wasn't necessarily actively threatening
to invade russia per se whereas you know
provocation
um on the mexican you know border with
the united states or canadian border you
know that is
there's what reason would it have other
than territorial expansion as proven in
2014 2013 and now in 2022 it's not it's
not like putin hasn't
he hasn't demonstrated that he's willing
to uh take have territorial aspirations
for what he perceives as a benefit to
him so
i i think it would be somewhat different
right than just to say nato now uh you
know or mexico now joins the warsaw pact
which doesn't exist but
i
i really don't know what to say brian
a lot of us were very concerned about
what the reasoning was
um in extending
you know nato status to latvia
you know it's super close to moscow and
it's like
is it a thousand miles maybe even inside
um
[Music]
and
you know you can
there's a lens where you get to say wow
these are sovereign states they get to
do whatever they choose to do who's to
tell them that sounds like paternalism
you know
okay
you're talking about the world
i mean i i just i can't shake this
that wasn't pushback that you just did
i mean
we know
putin is a bad guy
i want us to win
i don't need i don't want to be unclear
about that
we're talking about the world
we're talking about a habitable world a
world in which we recognize buildings
from antiquity where
it's relatively safe to breathe the air
i don't know what conversation we're
having i'm just very confused by it
when you have article 5 status in nato
and you
decide that you've got peacetime
careerists who want to
burnish their resumes by
saying i'm the president who extended uh
nato to more countries that happened
under my watch
and you're not really thinking about the
idea this goes back to stephen pinker's
idea that we're living in the most
blessed era of all time right where and
you know i'm having the same issue over
and over again with the economist with
price indices all of these people
they look at certain terms in the
equation without looking at the whole
equation and then they decide i'm seeing
enough of the equation that i can draw
strong conclusions
and what we have is a world saturated in
potential violence in the form of
nuclear weapons biological weapons fuel
air weapons are incredibly terrifying uh
the the the weapons of demoralization
that make you know why does japan
capitulate at the end of world war ii
the way it does is because somebody's
brought the fire of the sun to japanese
soil
you know
yeah you actually made a very
provocative statement but i think it on
further reflection has uh
some merit to it which will probably
shock most of my listeners than that you
were advocating
for the detonation of a of a fusion
device not a fission device uh at some
point in the past maybe it was 2019 uh
to kind of reiterate and shake the dust
off of the complacency
that uh that were you you know looking
into your you know patented crystal ball
back then and and uh i mean wha what was
that based on at that point because eric
we both know you know this guy lawrence
krauss has been a guest on my show uh
and people like shelly glashow friend of
uh the show as well
and they're on this thing called the
bulletin of the atomic scientist
and every day you know trump woke up and
tweeted they were moving the the second
hand
do you feel like your
client or your uh you know kind of uh
proposal shall i say to do this was
really encounter to that kind of cry
wolf effect that they kept increasing it
over pet like the woman's march okay now
we need to move it up i mean was that in
response to that because it was way
before george floyd it was way before
covet it was way before years
look why why why was that front of mind
for you why was i on the twin nuclei
problem we just spent you know how many
years living indoors not attending our
our loved ones funerals with masks over
our faces having no idea whether they
work not really understanding what we're
injecting into our bodies
um
i was warning you about the twin nuclei
problem have we done that for people
that might be new to your thoughts sure
that
in less than six months between 1952 and
53 we unlocked the secrets of the
nucleus of the cell in the form of
three-dimensional structure of dna
followed by the genetic code 10 years
later
and we unlocked the ability to fuse
nuclei with the teller ulam device
and
those i guess iv mic was our first
nuclear test in 52.
um
a fusion device first fusion device
right and
those innovations
made uh
humans capable of their own extinction
by just fiddling around with power that
we don't know how to control we know how
to unlock it you know
but we don't know how to control it so
if you give somebody um
you know
a bottle of jack daniels a ferrari and a
machine gun
[Music]
they can have a pretty interesting time
just getting to know their
their new friends
i don't know what we're doing i i'm so
flipped out and i was calling for
a turn a return to rare above
above-ground atmospheric nuclear tests
because i don't believe in their absence
human beings will actually do the
computation of what we're talking about
we're having the most irrelevant
discussions
as long as ukraine looks like um house
to house fighting and as long as
zelinsky is telegenic
and by the way you know bruce willis is
stepping away from acting
it's funny because i was saying that
zelensky you know is the ultimate sort
of bruce willis character
uh when he's offered uh you know the
ability to evacuate he says
i need ammunition
not a ride you know it's like wow uh
that that plays well because eo's mother
comrades
yeah
comrade
um
we're crazy i i can't i can't go to
parties
i was just at a party i was a complete
pill
um i i've been telling people if you
don't watch the cell and the atom
you can have all the bitcoin
conversations you want all the
conversations about liquid democracy and
institutional reform and web three
it's just like
nobody's paying attention we are
sleepwalking to armageddon and what i
learned from from the invasion of
ukraine
is that what i was trying to do with my
show
was to wake people up
and vladimir putin just said hold my
beer
and
everybody hit the snooze button i mean
we're talking about ukraine it's not
like we're not talking about it but
we're talking about it
you know do we think putin will
capitulate is he out of options we turn
everything into a soap opera right just
like do you want this guy cornered and
weak i certainly don't okay and do you
want to talk about you know he cannot be
allowed to remain in power and then you
know biden has to walk by i didn't mean
regime change
um
we've got
children
i've got a 79 year old child
as the president of the united states
and then i did the computation
it was 116 days where harry truman went
from the ceremonial role
of vice president of the united states
largely ceremonial position
to being the one to drop two atomic
devices on civilians
and military in
hiroshima nagasaki
the person who currently holds harry
truman's old job
is kamala harris
now you
i'm not supposed to be able to say
anything about kamala harrison
because she's both female and uh a
person dark of hue
and the answer is no
um kamala harris isn't really fit for
that job and it's evident i don't need
to go
into detail um
the idea that you can't even speak in
our society to say obvious things like
there's something weird going on with
women's swimming
uh or even answer what is a woman right
that became controversial last week
right so in essence um
the media in my estimation and our tech
giants are
while zielinski is talking about a
no-fly zone our own media is enforcing a
no think zone there will be no thinking
there will be no thinking in public
there will be no communication of
thoughts
every conversation will be turned
towards white supremacy and bigotry and
it's time to clear these idiots off the
stage because right now we've got a
nuclear situation and i i don't know how
to say no i think i think you're being
abundantly clear and speaking of stages
you ever see like one of these
performers you know like dua lipa
or uh
ariana grande who are you know
undoubtedly talented individuals but
they're i saw a video and they're
singing on stage and they're having fun
and then accidentally the mic slips out
of dua lipa's hand and it rolls into the
crowd but somehow she keeps singing with
the same amplitude and same you know
delightful modulation in other words
it's all a sham it's all she's just
lip-syncing to something that she
recorded she had genuine talent but but
maybe there's
and and i feel like we're doing that as
a as a society like the the speakers
have dropped their microphones and we're
pretending like they're singing it they
just raise their voices
and they they won't get off the stage
they can't get off the stage
it's inherent in who they are
okay so let's assume that that's true
the problem is not them
the problem is us
let's start with me the problem is me
i had this show i've got a giant
audience
people say where's the portal why aren't
you doing any new shows and i'm thinking
do you know how nerd you are to
everything
you've decided that uh
jordan peterson brett weinstein joe
rogan maybe brian keating
everybody sam harris i can tell you the
the the things that go around about
every single person as to why we can't
listen to anyone who's not on script
i have failed
vladimir putin
has failed
now
i i'm i'm spending my days split between
two separate activities for the most
part one is
trying to get us options
trying to figure out what it is we can
do so that if we don't agree with
zielinski putin
biden
and kim and we don't we don't feel that
they've got this
um
what do we do i mean it's sort of funny
like elon is talking about all this
stuff he's on the same planet the rest
of our the rest of us are
so
i
the other thing that i'm doing when i'm
not trying to do physics and trying to
think about how we get out of here
um is to try to figure is there any way
to wake us up and it just doesn't seem
to be possible it seems to be that
there's some interface
between media tech and the human mind
that until the human mind gets the
message from cnn and in the new york
times hey we've been lying about
everything we're in great danger we have
the wrong leadership we need resources
completely redirected i mean let me just
be very pointed about it
um are you familiar with the anton
chagour character in no country for old
men
uh very very very vaguely yes okay
at some point he's about to kill woody
harrelson in a hotel room with a
silenced shotgun or a suppressed shock
and he asks he says may i ask you a
question
always polite if the path uh
that you followed led you to this of
what use was the path
so if you want to think about markets
and you want to think about democracy
and you want to think about the american
experiment
if the path we've led
has got us with a 79 year old commander
in chief about 10 years
almost 10 years older than the oldest
president ever in history
if that person has a 5
plus chance of dying in any 12-month
period
according to the u.s social security
administration men's health statistics
79 year old u.s mail
if his running mate was kamala harris
who was almost certainly chosen for
diversification reasons in part just the
way he announced that he was going to
make sure that his next supreme court
appointment was a
african-american female
and nasa by the way uh has made an
announcement that it wants
a woman
and a person of color on the moon both
of which are awesome things to have but
why make a point of it i have no
that's their mission statement so you're
talking about the artemis program which
has in their twitter profile again you
know the way conservatives would do this
is they'd say um you know condoleezza
rice uh you know the first person to
hold this and then they'd be done with
it they wouldn't hold a week-long
celebration and talk about you know
powerful black females
there's just a difference in sort of
seriousness of purpose and temperament
we can't talk about any of this so if we
if the path of democracy and markets
have led us to kamala harris being a
heartbeat away from a guy who has a 5
chance of dying in any 10-year period in
any one-year period
uh at age 79 and declining cognition
with vladimir putin landing shells if i
understand
between 10 and 15 miles from the polish
border which has enjoyed full article 5
mutual protection status since i think
1999.
have we built a doomsday machine in
other words if you view all of our
interlocking agreements our markets
our
laws our cultures our understandings as
a machine and we
are simply the subroutines
does this machine
end
with a halting problem
does this machine effectively bring
humanity to a close not because any
particular person willed it but because
we kept piling up new instructions and
we didn't check the code that it was
actually going to run and run
indefinitely exactly
you know just to finish to finish this
up
we've all failed and i feel like i
failed more than any of you because if i
go back to my old stuff you know people
say are you going to sit around and say
i told you so well for sure i'm going to
tell say i told you so because i've been
on this for years
but
because i told you so i also know that i
failed because i got the audience
right and a huge audience i said exactly
this beware the twin nuclei we spent two
years plus under covid which is probably
something involving peter desjack and
the wuhan lab but we haven't even
bothered to investigate it
and now we've got vladimir putin um
miscalculating in ukraine and we're sort
of chirpy about the idea that this is
going to be an exercise in masculinity
and we like zelinski's brand better than
puffy putin emerging from covet this
these are the twin nuclei people this is
exactly what i warned you about and
because i told you so i failed more than
any of the rest of you
well you know i wanna
you know i appreciate the humility and i
believe it's sincere and and i want to
just count and countenance the the
following uh uh subject so we i just
started teaching in person for the first
time in three years uh and it's uh it
was a little bit you know not
trepidatious anything to do with covet
or anything but just like wow do i still
have it you know i've done i i started
you know communicating via youtube and
everything you know into the pandemic
two years ago actually i think this is
our two year anniversary of doing
podcasts together by the way my friend
um yeah so uh so there have been you
know that was at least one good thing
that came out of covid besides staying
uh home a lot with my uh with my family
but um but i'm back in person i'm
teaching students i'm i'm enjoying the
the feels of it all and some of them are
undoubtedly watching this episode but
i'm also enjoying being with my graduate
students and it reminded me we're
recruiting graduate students we have a
bumper crop of some of the most amazing
students coming to uc san diego to work
with me and my colleagues here and uh
and the the fact is when i start off
with a new grand student i tell him or
her and i say look what you're about to
do is complicated but it's not complex
in other words uh think about a 787.
it's it's very complicated you know no
one person can build a pencil let alone
a 787 dreamliner but if you follow the
steps the blueprints you have the
materials you put them in together in
the right order a 787 is sure to emerge
on the other hand if you tell me to make
a sand pile with exactly so many grains
of sand with exactly these dimensions
that's impossible to do because of
sensitivity and true underlying
complexity or predicting the planetary
phenomenon like the weather you need
something of the size of the earth to
predict accurately model the climate uh
and so i think there's merit to this
testing idea that you're that you're
talking about because the only way to
really model the effects maybe on
society and and our collective conscious
would be the detonation of this device
and i do i'm not advocating it for a
person i'm just saying there's merit to
this idea because you cannot simulate
the effect of a complex process without
the complexity of the process itself but
i want to turn from that to say
uh really what do you think would happen
the next day and i posed this to lex
friedman when i was on his show late
last year earlier this year actually and
i said what do you think lex would
happen the day after we discover aliens
and and since you joined the project
galileo with avi loeb i want to get your
feedback on this too what do you think
would happen the day after we discover
aliens are
and
well
i mean it's an interesting question i i
can tell you what happened uh on
september 12th
of 2001 because everybody remembers
september 11th uh
who went through it
um what i was fascinated by in addition
to that was
september 12th because in a world where
we're not mostly narcissistically eager
to share who we are what we think
we didn't want to say anything most of
the very loud voices recognize that
something had happened and
that thing that had happened had
grave
impact on the culture ourselves the
families affected directly
um
[Music]
you know i i think that when israel went
through
1973's yom kippur war after the
brilliant victory in 1967
it was a humbling experience because
they'd gotten high on their own supply
we had gotten high on our own supply
that there was a magical force field
protecting the united states
saw almost no action during world war ii
there was a little bit of stuff from
japanese subs and i think around santa
barbara i'm not quite sure
but the mainland of the us was basically
untouched
so i think what
would happen after aliens is that either
we would actually be
transformed and and silenced and quiet
and humbled
or
the change that has been brought about
by the smartphone and all of the
innovation since september 11th
would cause us to continue to dreamwalk
that we would we would want to know if
we could get selfies we want to know
whether we could turn the aliens into an
nft
um
[Music]
i think we've gone mad
and i'm not positive how to answer
how a mad civilization
would respond i can tell you that i i'm
pretty sure that if this had happened in
the 70s
it would have been very very different
we we were smarter than
you know we were being lied to but we
were being lied to lessened by fewer
people and it wasn't quite so chaotic
right um centralized right you know so
there were a lot there lots of things
are much much better it's not it's not
the 70s were some golden era it's just
we've become
almost unforgivably psychotic
collectively i i don't know how to
i don't know how to to sugarcoat this i
feel like
um
i am so far away from planet earth at
the moment in my understanding of what
i'm watching what's on the line what the
odds are
you know and again i as you can see i've
clearly gone through
a bunch of attempts to estimate what are
our risks until
until the looking glass of the
tech
and the media reflect our reality i now
believe
that we are in i don't know if you've
ever seen an ant mill where ants leave
these like pheromone trails
yeah and the danger is is that they'll
make a circle
and so the ants will go into a death
spiral by just following a trail that
goes infinitely and they'll die circling
you know effectively an object
i feel like we're in an ant mill
and
this particular ant
i went out
so we can either resolve to
you know
give in which i don't see in your nature
or to fight
and you're you know you're fighting
you're you're
you're you're out there you're in public
you're not afraid to admit
uh you know where you've changed your
mind if you've been wrong
and that you're uh irrepressibly
passionate about your projects of course
one of them is is gu which you
revealed on this very podcast uh exactly
a year ago on april fool's day
um
let me ask you again with i'll do
tenderness and respect
by what you know by what virtue does one
look into the equations of uh quantum
field theory say and from it divine a
nuclear device in other words where does
the engineering begin and the physics
take over the the transistor is another
example we didn't really look at the
laws of quantum mechanics they said this
this filament-like act or this this
whisker of of a semiconductor with
certain impurities uh when engineered
and put in contact uh and sufficiently
close proximity behaves this way oh and
then we can explain it using
schrodinger's equation we didn't look
into schrodinger's equation to find the
transistor so to what extent
could one be serious about looking at
string theory
loop quantum gravity or whatever you
want gu
and look into those equations and get
off of this marble
you know and what what kind of walk me
through that that process sure
so first of all let's talk about the old
discovery um there are
there were civil war veterans
who saw action at places like antietam
who witnessed the hydrogen bomb in 1952.
the big discovery i think was 1932
was the neutron
and
the you know the i have a living ant in
philadelphia who is older than the
neutron so when you make a discovery
it's not necessarily the quantum
mechanics but the
structure
of the nucleons and
and nuclei
um gave lisa meitner uh a woman who did
not get enough credit for getting us
into this mess
um and may get us out who knows uh right
or blame yeah
sh
you know her discovery was
i don't know six years later five years
later not very long after that and then
teller and ulam figured out how to take
a fission device
and turn it into a fusion
precursor by focusing the geometry
uh
of the the blast from the fission device
and reflecting it back into a second
stage which actually produces the fusion
so
it was sort of a combination of
engineering and geometry much more than
it was
innovations in quantum field theory and
then what it did is it it sort of
it taught
the physics community that they weren't
impotent
that they could do things
and almost immediately after they
remembered that they were actually
capable of doing things
they went back to quantum field theory
and basic understanding of the universe
and so you have shelter island and
pocono and old stone conferences which
changed everything in physics
in the late 1940s 1947-48
right now what we have is we have a
theoretical physics community that is in
the same situation before the manhattan
project where
we'd done great work uh the standard
model of the time was called qed but we
couldn't compute with it
and then once people like feynman
you know had a chance to shine at los
alamos
we started holding conferences where we
were really looking for solutions and
almost immediately we were back back on
track so i have to imagine that as
horrible as the products of the
manhattan project were their effect on
the theoretical physics community was to
take them out of being a cargo cult that
only got infinities
and turned them into extremely capable
engineers so that they could go back to
being extremely capable physicists
so right now
the way in which this would work is
we don't know whether we we can get off
this planet and by that i really mean
get out of the solar system
if we're going to be here with general
relativity and that's the last word you
can you understand why elon and
richard branson and jeff bezos are
focused on rocketry
what we don't understand is why rich
people aren't focused on getting rid of
general relativity as a fundamental
theory and making it an effective theory
so that we can find out whether the true
fundamental theory below it
has new possibilities and new degrees of
freedom and new opportunities for
engineering and escape
and again the point isn't that if we go
to another planet we're not going to
bring our madness with it it's that some
of us may not be crazy enough to blow
ourselves up and at the moment we're
talking about the lowest common
denominator and the lowest common
denominator may very well be vladimir
putin or kim
and that might be the sand grain that is
unpredictable that topples the pile uh
but do you think i mean if we were
talking on a
on a zoom call or
uh back in you know 380 a.d uh in the
you know
waning uh era of the roman empire uh i
mean are some of these things just
translation invariant they also built a
sophisticated civilization with a lot of
old you know people in charge at the top
and and plenty of uh young people of the
of the societal pyramid and uh and
hungry for bread and circus
and for uh you know look at the the all
the accoutrements that we have we just
call them tiktok and and instagram uh do
you think this is a time translation
invariant process but made worse by the
ratchet effect of the power awesomeness
power i don't understand what
conversation we're having again and
again forgive me because clearly i don't
i'm not a good conversationalist anymore
um
[Music]
well presumably there was still uh you
know aryan and dravidian civilization in
the subcontinent or there were iroquois
and and and uh sioux precursors
during the roman empire
and you know my claim is is that not all
our eggs were in one basket right but
right now all of our eggs are in one
basket called earth
and
you know maybe the idea is that i should
first just limit myself to the subset of
people who find it really important that
humans have an indefinite future
i mean a lot of young people i don't
understand why do humans have to have an
indefinite future it's like a perfectly
reasonable question get it away from me
you know well they did a study a famous
study there they asked olympic hopefuls
if they trade you know 30 years of life
expectancy for a gold medal and 50
percent of them said yes
uh there there is this tab but i guess
what i'm saying is you're right of
course now we're playing with fire for
the first time in nuclear fire right um
so that's of course true on the other
hand it's not whole society if if putin
were removed from the equation if he was
for god's sakes not allowed to remain in
power uh you know just like lee harvey
oswald a single individual changed the
world for the worse and it's much easier
for single individuals to worsen the
world than for individuals to make it
better
right so what i'm trying to say is
that's going to keep happening
yeah the key question is whether the
single individual in question
has leverage
if you've got nuclear leverage or
biological leverage we get trouble
because those things those levers are so
levered right the amount of power
i mean literally i view this as sneaking
into god's toolbox and just rummaging
around
um you know you know as an atheist i say
this
brian i i don't know how to communicate
this i can i
it's self-evident
it's self-evident to me that this is
where we are and it's self-evident to me
that
like
there is only one plan
yeah
every plan for survival
involves tasking the people who got us
into this mess because francis crick was
a physicist teller was a physicist ulam
was a physicist that was a geometer
you have to task the exact same people
who got you in to get you out and that
may be
unfortunate you may say well you built
the titanic and hear it sinking
go make sure that you build us some
lifeboats
yeah and you're like no i'm not gonna
trust that guy he built the titanic look
these are the only boat builders you've
got did
which part of this here's my question
brian
this is like a four line proof
the only way out of this conundrum
assume that it's three percent odds
assume that you're playing roulette in
either a european wheel or an american
wheel i guess the american wheel has two
green
yeah zero zero and zero
and the europeans have one and otherwise
there's something like 36 red and and
black
things okay assume that that's the case
how many times do you get to spin this
thing before it comes up green
no one knows and not that many
yes it's unlikely but you can't keep
playing this game
all right that's the first thing next
question is if that's true
give me the total list of escape
scenarios like one thing that you may
not know
that i only know because i've recently
found myself in circles of people who
have 10 figures and up
is that a lot of very rich people are
thinking about personal escapes from
armagedd
they're not thinking about the bunkers
or yeah bunkers different countries
yachts whatever
okay
this is ridiculous i mean for only only
in limited situations is that a great
plan
there's only one thing to do which is to
ask
how do we get ourselves diversification
so that as you point out these conserved
features of collapsing civilizations
don't take down the permanent human
enterprise
and that's why you know i'm going to a
bitcoin conference in miami
um and i think that the talk is supposed
to be they usually say fix the money fix
the world
and i think i have a change to fix the
money leave the world
the importance of decentralization in
space faring
uh if bitcoin is a protocol uh how does
it work if you're multi-planetary uh if
you're in different star systems or
you're kardashev three or have infinite
free energy right yeah or do you have a
different situation whereby the point of
bitcoin is to start working on a
decentralized option like from
decentralization to decentralization the
key point of failure
is that we're all sharing one
terrestrial surface now bezos or bezos i
don't know how to pronounce his last
name talks about like gerald k o'neill
cylinders and maybe stanford taurei
where you get artificial gravity through
centripetal
acceleration um
elon is focused on the moon not quite
sure what branson is doing but the point
is all of these people at least have the
nub of the idea we've got to diversify
and with all that money
i don't ever want to hear about a
theoretical physicist
who isn't putting three kids through uh
private schools with a second home a
pension secured and the ability to check
in into any four seasons anywhere on
planet earth
i mean this is obscene the only people
who can save us are mathematicians and
physicists
and we don't know that it's possible
it's quite possible that they could
return a final theory
and we could look at it and say yep
einstein was right the final theory
doesn't contain any new options that the
one
faster than like travel don't no
we don't know and until we know and
until we hold the conferences we're
still instead held hostage to an
economic system
that is is mostly there to protect
people born
in like the 1940s and 50s so that they
can live out their days pretending that
they're doing physics while they do
geometric
analysis inspired by physics which they
might call string theory or topological
quantum field theory or toy models or
conformal field theory it's like no
it's now time to get back to physics
it's now time
to do what old stone pocono and shelter
island did as conferences which is to
reignite the physics community get the
smart people in here and here's the
dumbest thing and i'm just embarrassed
to say it but here goes
physics built your entire economy more
or less suitably understood from biotech
to communications to the world wide web
to the semiconductor
the dumbest thing in the world is money
or tokens
go get us a huge pile
drop it off and go away did you ever
hear the joke einstein i'm not done
brother
i gotta tell a joke that you're getting
too heavy no i'm not getting too heavy
you're getting too light listen to me
for just a second and i don't mean to be
overbearing
this is the dumbest thing in the world
it's just resource
you're going to put it down on
on a gulf stream or you're going to put
it down on a private island or you're
going whatever you're going to do
it doesn't have anything like the
leverage
of making sure that the people who built
your economy are cut in as wealthy
people who are independent enough to say
no edwin no david gross
no
university i'm not going to do your
stupid bidding i'm not going to bow down
to diversity equity and inclusion
we're not going to we're not going to
adulterate what we know how to do if it
has the opportunity to save us all
and the idea that we can't even get
resource into theoretical physics
differential geometry
is an obscenity
we built this goddamn thing and then you
we're in an agreement you society or an
agreement which is we're not going to
let you commercialize this you're you're
frozen out of intellectual property oh
what do we get out of the equation
oh you get institutional protection
you get academic freedom well you you
got rid of that you turn the
universities into a monstrosity so that
we can flatter our undergraduates
because what you did is you used it
to extract wealth from the young and
give it to the old now the universities
are broken they don't work the stupid
thing is go get us a pile of money and
leave us alone and tell us to work on
getting you the hell out of here because
we got you in here
and
that message is so simple and it doesn't
resonate it's got no resonance
and i've given up i mean all i sit
around doing for the most part is doing
quantum field theory i'm giving up tons
of money
i'm not doing much of much of anything
else
because i'm i'm trying to make sure my
kids my at least my my clan has a future
and i i believe this
we we've forgotten
there was no possibility of building an
atomic weapon
in 1930 because we didn't know about the
neutron
almost immediately after you had the
neutron you had atomic power and atomic
weapons right
we don't know what physics is about to
unlock and when you look at that james
webb telescope and you look at it
peering out into the cosmos imagine that
it is possible that if we can get beyond
einstein's theory that you won't be
talking about faster than light because
space time is an einsteinian concept
you'll be talking about something that
you have no idea what the words are
and it may be possible to visit the
universe so that you're not deciding
between koh samui and tulum
you know i mean it's just it's really
important to recognize that more or less
we're here on one spec
time to go and
let me just say the last thing
i hate how how heavy and overbearing
this is but wake the hell
up
like you've seen this in ukraine you're
not putting it together because the
person on television is not telling you
you're running a three percent five
percent one percent risk something like
that of total annihilation right now
thanks
well okay so i have to inject some
levity at this point so einstein dies
eric he goes to shemin he goes up to
heaven
and there he encounters several
individuals first one comes up to him he
says hello young lady what's your
what's your iq
she says it's 156.
great
talk about math physics
geometry
space travel wormholes etc
then i meet somebody else what's your iq
130 uh oh great we can talk about
politics and life and law and something
you need someone what's your iq it's a
96. oh great we could talk about the
stock market
um because yeah you're saying that this
is and no offense to my all my day
trading bitcoin friends out there i'll
shoot my laser beam eyes at you someday
uh but uh but the point being yes this
should be a problem that physics can
solve and actually you and pia and
others have made contributions to a
physicalization
of an economic system which is which is
rather brilliant and i'll be a topic for
another show and you have given lectures
in uh recent places like the university
of chicago and elsewhere upon you've
been all around the world on a college
tour but i want to say you are um you're
sounding dark you're you're darker now
uh than than i've heard but let me
finish let me finish but i want to give
you hope i come to bring you hope um
hope and light as the president biden
just said uh because you're able to do
something uniquely uh so you don't look
at a honeybee and say could you that's
great you know the honey is sweet could
you make me a web like i really need a
web no you say i want some more of that
honey and likewise with a spider you
don't say oh make me some honey you have
a unique gift you could do science you
can do physics but you can also reach
out to literally millions around the
world you have a huge platform and and
you use it very uh with great with great
gravitas and i think it's more than most
people do
and of course the haters oh he's a guru
he's a svengali
let's ignore them they're it's not worth
discussing however
you do have an ability to inspire and
and build a lifeboat and provide
preservers
i'm not optimistic about getting off the
planet with gu or string theory or loop
quantum gravity in my lifetime but what
about my grandkids you're hopefully
going to be a grandfather
that was my point about the neutron
if if you had a correct theory that was
a major upgrade
why wouldn't you be optimistic within a
very short window
you don't know is my point you don't
know but just not knowing is not proof
that it will happen for you know that
that that why the galileo project is so
important you see
if
we can escape
this is again very short syllogism if we
can escape to the cosmos then the cosmos
can visit here right very simple
if we found out that we are being
visited
and that we are being visited by
something that wants to be cryptic
because it doesn't want to be fully
known
there's precedent for that north
sentinel island does not probably
understand that india exists but india
claims north sentinel island even though
the north sentinelese
don't speak any hindi
or tamil or whatever
we don't know what language they speak
um
if we can leave
they can visit and if they can visit it
means
that the next iteration contains power
just the way the physics before the
neutron
had a lot less power than physics with
the neutron right
so
if the galileo project is successful in
convincing us that there is something to
visitation
then suddenly everything changes and and
this is something people are embarrassed
again they will immediately compute the
social consequence of saying aliens
right and then there'll be a roswell
thing and and everything everything
degenerates into giggles just the way
every conversation
right every conversation about sex uh
you know super important force that
determines the world but we can't talk
about it without giggling right so we
have the same thing with aliens um
and in that world uh you start to
understand that the odds that we're
alone in in the cosmos
are are negligible
and if people
can leave
intelligence can visit
and we need to know that that's possible
if somebody told you it is possible to
visit the cosmos because einstein isn't
the last word
you double your efforts and if they told
you you know it's much easier than
you're making it out to be and it isn't
an infinite journey because people will
say all of these idiotic things they'll
say oh i think that they're an infinite
number of problems and people have
always thought they were getting to the
end well people thought they were
getting to the end of of
intercontinental exploration and then we
found the last land mass off the north
of siberia and we were done
right so
these things do come to an end no they
do they do and
but but i guess to get back to the you
know inspirational motivational part of
the speech
um you have this ability and not knowing
in the future
uh i i feel like that comes with it a
responsibility not to say i failed and
now i'm gonna take my uh lashes and do
teshuva but but instead to say look i
have a unique platform i have
and focus entirely on inspiring
if that's what you want
make me
make me happy
bring me people
i need
i need people i need resources and i
need them now okay lawyers guns and
money well i offered you people here
and money i i just think that warren
zivan belong this is the first smart
thing we've said today
send lawyers guns and money but really
instead of lawyers i need differential
geometers particle theorists
and i need money that is not encumbered
and i need people not to [ __ ] and moan
about the fact that scientists
are comfortable and fearless and not
writing grants let's stop this grant
cycle let's get them away from
undergraduates give me wait no brian
give me these people and i will go back
to telling jokes playing the guitar
playing the piano i will be the sunny
host of the portal but right now
i haven't been on the air for years or
you know for over a year i'm telling you
this is the emergency
you know it's not that i'm sitting here
every second and saying we're all going
to die of covet i didn't know that
i can tell you this if you keep running
this putin experiment and you do several
versions of it we will all die
or or whatever world is left will not be
the one that you want your children to
be living in and right now
if if this doesn't get your attention i
need to separate from my audience i
don't want to entertain you
where you don't understand what's on the
line this is not life is beautiful well
i'm pretending that you know a
concentration camp isn't the death camp
i don't think i'm asking to pretend that
i'm asking one one of two things which i
don't think can simultaneously be true
one is that you're saying scientists
need to focus a hundred percent on what
scientists do without the diversity bs
and this thing and that thing and the
bureaucratic bs and grant writing
what was that get out but then you're
also my friend you're also saying that
like scientists do a a crappy job of
selling the best script that's ever been
written which is the scientific
enterprise and that we don't do it and
you have people like edwin and others
if hbo wants me to do a show to get
people excited i will do you have a show
what you have a show that's bigger than
most uh cnn broadcasts i don't have a i
don't have a budget for the huge
graphics with the 3d and the projection
mapping all the stupid [ __ ] if that's
the stuff that excites you
will somebody else handle it right now
what i want to be looking at is bundles
partial differential equations fields
operators hilbert spaces
and i'm happy
to share what's going on with it i'm
happy to talk about what we i'm actually
not talking about you i'm not
criticizing you i'm saying that you want
to insulate scientists and give us the
academic freedom freedom that we were
promised and i love talking to people
brian but
hold on let me let me finish please i
want to say i don't feel like my other
colleagues are engaging with the public
in a way that is uh is going to further
this project that you're describing in
other words they sit we sit in our in
our offices or our laboratories and we
just do what we're supposed to we never
talk to the public we never communicate
what we're doing with their money and so
of course why should i give you more
money you just told me like i can't
understand if i could understand what
you're doing it wouldn't be worth a
nobel prize right fineman uh so to what
extent do we scientists have an
obligation to have portals of our own
present company excluded well you know
you're doing i'm doing it i'd rather be
doing that stuff but
um what stuff wait sorry you'd rather be
doing what
look
when i like to take a break from
actually doing research on something or
thinking about something or building
something or whatever it is i love
talking to people i'm a social person i
like explaining what i know
turning everything into interpersonal
drama or turning everything into a
market or turning everything into a game
theoretic exercise is killing
what we knew how to do even a short time
ago so i would love to do
you know half a day's worth of uh you
know actual
research
equations
whatever and then i'd like to record
something but if i'm going to record
something i just want to spill into a
studio and i want to tell somebody you
know in a week's time get these things
worked up as graphics i don't want to
think about payroll i don't want to
think about human resources i don't want
to think about uh whether it's sponsors
and all right well it's like i record in
this room with a lot of glass all the
audio engineers complain dude you should
really
you know cover your dining room in in
tarps
that's gonna be great for for my family
where i've taken over the dining room
and covered it in tarps
i'm just
i care about two things here one i care
about inspiring people
and two i care about getting people a
future
and
i'm looking at the people i'm trying to
inspire and i'm trying to get a future
for
and they don't even know what risk
they're in and they don't appreciate it
and they turn things into drama because
they're not strong enough to to
withstand like all the voices
of you know like if the lancet says well
this definitely didn't come from a lab
in wuhan well who am i i guess the
lancet said it it's important to
recognize that we can inspire people
but if i can't even get you to wake up
and i can't even get somebody in the
government
to to understand ideas have consequences
ulam and teller's ideas have great
consequences
we are not
brian i've spent a year
i have more or less told people why i
believe there are three generations of
fermions a year ago
i've not had a single physicist on
planet earth
say
i want to talk to you about why you say
there are three generations of fermions
i gave a reason why the world appears to
be chiral but actually is not chiral
why it appears that the weak force beta
decay
knows it's left from its right maximally
violating of c yeah
and
i have not had one person
come to me and say
i want to talk to you about that
um
do you think it's credentialism you're
not in academia you're seen as an
outsider i get i get literally
it's not me brian
it's not me it's the field
when peter white
came out with his idea
um
which was to build it around uh the
group su-3 which has the strong
communicates the strong force which is
what holds
nuclei together when the protons want to
run away from each other packed in so
tightly
i made sure to read what he wrote and i
called him up and he said yeah nobody's
calling
now i don't have to agree with him but
at least understand what he did do
and i wanted to make absolutely sure
that i grasped the general idea
what i'm trying to tell you is i knew
that no one was going to much call peter
no one is listening to each other
there's almost no one working on physics
and i i think that that's the real
statement this is that the question is
maybe what does the community say
the community basically isn't doing
physics go to your local uh
university's physics you know high
energy theory seminar and i challenge
you to listen to a talk
uh and find anything that sounds like
physics in it in general it sounds like
oh we're in six dimensions we've got a a
compact simple group
um and we look at the following fields
that nobody's ever seen in human history
we treat it super symmetrically even
though we've never seen supersymmetry
we're not working
and the the economists aren't doing
economics
i i think the extent to which people
imagine that this system is continuing
to do what it once did until you
actually release new ideas you don't get
to see
that
it's not an airport it's a cargo cult
[Music]
i want you uh
to react to this statement by uh
past guest on the show albert einstein
einstein said the following about two
different dynamics of of human
capability he called the and this is
from a book called the the metaphoric
mind by bob samples he said
albert einstein called the intuitive or
metaphoric mind a sacred gift
he added that the rational mind
was a faithful servant
it is a paradoxical it is paradoxical
that in the context of modern life
we have begun to worship the servant and
to defile the divine oh i love it
so
do you see it possible to have both
signs the intuitive metaphoric the
sacred gift the divine and that rational
sorry gohan he had both i mean this is
this is the interesting thing right
which is
[Music]
what was it inspiration is more
important than knowledge imagination
imagine like the center for human
imagination
right
um
the rational people are all you know
great spirits have always encountered
violent opposition from mediocre minds
in order to make huge advances you have
to be wrong in the process
and what you find is you try to imagine
uh e e cummings turning in a poem
and a copy editor saying the
capitalization is off the punctuation is
wrong the grammar is non-existent
yeah no kidding it's e cummings
um
great minds
have to be able to do things that are
wrong
when derock you know came up with his
equation he had numbers where a times b
wasn't b times a
and it wasn't until he realized that
there were matrices that he could make
sense of what he'd written if you can't
go through wrong you can't advance and
thought the positron was the proton
right that's true um
and galileo thought the tides were
caused by uh the orbit of the earth not
the moon so in all of these situations
um
you've got this sort of copy editing
group that's always angry because it
never wins the answer is stop being a
copy editor you have to is that why you
think gu is experiencing get has
experienced you know kind of passions
and opposition or do you think it's
people realizing what are you saying
about that i haven't had almost any gu
conversations
well you know i was thinking about that
as you were saying we we talked
yesterday the day before
you know
our mutual friend stephan alexander
whose birthday it was yesterday old man
i missed it yeah it's okay uh he didn't
he didn't reply to my uh video text uh
but maybe maybe he was uh having having
fun instead but you know he's got a
theory of everything he he works on uh
as his latest book
uh has come out you know kind of you
know is is the it's
everything yeah what's that he doesn't
have a theory of everything yeah he's
working on one
you mentioned peter white but you
mentioned we've talked about garrett
lisey
in other words i i don't know that we
have a dirt you know what if we have a
glut of theories of everything or are
unification geometric unification ideas
or what have you s
even you know shelly glashow has one
right so
i don't know
well i mean so5 or whatever he had right
that's u5 yes u5 yeah that's grand
unification yeah grant unit well i
always say we're putting the toe before
the gut you know because we don't have a
great grand unit but anyway some
geometric unit that will unlock powers
as you say beyond the atom the mere atom
which is already causing so much
devastation right so but my question is
you know maybe it's a supply problem
maybe there there are so many of these
things that how can anybody you are
unique but hold on a second hold on a
second because i have to compliment you
you're a handsome individual thank you
that will always stop
will always stop you from talking my
beautiful brother um but uh but the
point is
um not everyone's you right so not
everyone's able to to keep up with and
not everyone as i said to lex
is is as um commentus is as um you know
kind of collegial as you that will take
the time you know our mutual friend
sabino i don't have time for these
theories of everything you know he'll sh
wolfram weinstein lee but maybe
not everyone can do what you do let's
just be honest i mean you do you have a
special you know kind of arrangement
where your work is gives you flexibility
um perhaps i you know i actually we've
never really discussed your work and i
don't want to here but but the point
being how you know how can we expect the
young assistant professor you know down
the hall for me to get uh to get
involved in in curating and and doing a
rubric on these theories of
of unification
brian
let me just point out something that i
don't like in myself i don't like
talking over you
and i don't like
being
overbearing
but what you just said is so wrong
right i don't know how to be polite
about it you know it's not personal yeah
i i know it's operational it's like i'm
your devil's advocate that's not what's
going on you you're pulling the
conversation gravitationally back to
interpersonal
issues
sabine has enough time do i want to call
sabine a liar no she's being polite
she's meaning to say something else
it took me about 45 minutes to get the
gist of peter white's paper
the assistant professor you talk about
has 45 minutes to waste on all sorts of
things nobody works all the time on
their own stuff
my point is nobody's excited to look at
anybody else's work because they know
nothing is going to work now why they
know nothing is going to work i don't
know
but
what you're doing is you're using your
show
to spread the dumbest wrong thing about
something like geometric unity or peter
white's theory or garrett lisi's
anybody in our community can read those
things for ideas
right you can find the triality of the
three generations uh
source in in garrett's e8 theory even
though it's it's so 8 that has the
triality it sort of inherits
e8 inherits this you can read about how
peter white gets asymmetr asymmetry of
the weak force through su-2 through a
wick rotation inside complex 3-space
stephen wolfram has not actually you
know produced what i consider to be a
theory of everything although he's doing
his own thing and i think he should
continue to do it i'm not aware of
shelley glashow really having a
a bigger idea than grand unification
we all keep some track of these things
the question that you're trying to ask
me is something like
what's been the reaction to gu
and what i'm telling you is it's not
what you're saying
the reaction is i've lectured in two
places because of covid uh one in in
marseille in france and the other
university of chicago at the kaddanov
center i've had perfectly polite
conversations people are interested in
various aspects
but the the
academic
incentive structure
the ability to be viable
means that you've got to allow yourself
with people who can fund you and who can
hire you and who can give you tenure
and everyone's worried about their
reputation and nobody's worried about
physics
but when i say nobody i don't mean
absolutely nobody i had a great
conversation with for example nima
arkani hamed recently i was just gonna
say you you're right what was his
reaction then i mean was he willing to
engage it or was it polite
of course you know he's very
constructive you know his point is i i
learned a great deal from nema
and nima isn't like
i mean let me just say
nema in my estimation
is the soul of theoretical physics right
now
because he has an ability to do
something that i think almost no one
else does which is dead reckoning
he
we we've lost
sort of the the compass aheading from
experiment because the energy levels
have gotten prohibited for new for new
phenomena
we failed for a great deal of time so
most people are demoralized
theoretical physics lives
even when nima and i disagree or he says
something that's critical of me
that's what real critique is what he
told me to do is hey here are the sorts
of things that you can grab the
attention of the quantum field theory
community now i learned something very
very important which i would love to
discuss on the show
i think one of the big problems is that
there are these three legs to the
mathematical stool which is geometry
algebra and analysis i.e calculus
the problem with
quantum field theory is that it grew up
unbalanced it's really almost all
analysis and then we found out very late
in the day that we'd been neglecting
certain
topological geometric and algebraic
things and sort of starting in the 70s
with jim simons for the last 50 years
um people like ed whitton graham siegel
dan quillen
uh luis alvarez gomez have been
making
quantum field theory geometric and
that's been the basic
vector of success in the field
but what what you've come to understand
is that analysis is too brutal and crude
of a tool to have this responsibility
for carrying physics forward and i'll
give a simple example
if you have a function like a little
lump of probability that represents
where a particle can be
and then you try to propagate that
function
how do you know that the propagation of
that function isn't going to turn the
function negative in some places or how
do you know that the function as a lump
isn't going to start moving faster than
light and screw up causality or how do
you know that the integral of the
probability under that
function is going to remain 1.00
so
none of those things are really natural
inside of analysis but it seems like the
geometry and the
deeper algebraic principles ensure that
all of those things are true
and this goes back to something that you
know esther perel once said to me the
great relationship
coach
and therapist and she said the thing
about masculinity is that it's
incredibly powerful and just as fragile
in other words
a masculine male is an incredibly
powerful person
who
can be damaged um
by a single stray comment uh
you know from a woman and and cut low
and cut to the quick
that situation is true in quantum field
theory which is it's incredibly powerful
but it is just as fragile
and so what nema does which is different
is he says
here are all of the restrictions that
we've learned to place on things through
analysis
and it's a very long list and it's very
brittle so anytime you want to add
something everybody has the idea of how
do we know this is
going to this isn't going to screw up
what we've got uh
stuck together with masking tape and and
um paper clips and the like
in that sort of a setting
um
his point is here are some things that
we don't know how to do and if your
thing can do that that's the way to
speak to people who are dependent upon
analysis
that's an extremely constructive form of
criticism and feedback and i've taken
audience capture though i mean you're
like it's solving the sociological
problem of of getting something
palatable to your analytics no no
his point is he's explaining why quantum
field theorists have the prejudices that
they do
right like if you look at the loop
quantum gravity guys and people came out
of general relativity they're much more
unbalanced in the direction of geometry
and yeah
what we should have is a more balanced
community that learns how to redo
quantum field theory so that it works
automatically to give a very simple
example electromagnetism is four
equations if you do it the way maxwell
did through pure analysis
but if you do it through geometry
geometry enforces two out of the four so
you don't even have to mention them so
it cuts down the number of equations to
two and then those two become unified so
really there's only one maxwell equation
if you if you understand the geometry
what we're doing currently in quantum
field theory is it's a giant grab bag of
mostly analytic techniques
and that's why the quantum field theory
community has this sort of extreme
i don't know what to call it exactly
they're very guarded because
it's sort of like
they've built a hot rod that
can fall apart in an instant and has is
very finicky
and if we built something more robust
i think the field would be much more
intellectually healthy so i've learned a
lot by talking to i don't know just
spoke to alan guth at mit when i visited
um
so i'm talking to great people people
are being extremely positive polite
constructive
what you see online is you've got
you've got a different class and caliber
of people mostly people who've left the
field and sort of
you know try to score points by bitching
and
what i'm trying to do is i'm trying to
listen to the top people in the world
about what
what's the best way of communicating
with the with the community because i
think this is the world's most important
community
you think it's um
in the last say 15 minutes that we have
i mean do you think it's not unexpected
i mean the famous thomas kuhn structure
of scientific revolution is sort of you
know predicated on uh periods of
normalcy uh you know supplanted by
periods of crisis
when facts don't agree with uh with it
with uh
um you know kind of the accepted
paradigm and that leads to so-called
paradigm shift but these he said can
last for
decades generations you know lifetimes
and um you know i wonder if layering in
you know it's like options pricing right
i mean options are you know you you have
to get the price direction and the time
scale right so i'm wondering if if if
we're on balance um not really capable
of doing such a thing in physics where
you know the direction the field should
take and you're in the time scale that's
commensurate with tenure with
somebody's got to step in and rescue the
community from itself
and it has to be somebody with money and
to be honest i think bezos was a physics
major at princeton
or at least he was starting out in that
direction elon musk was one at the
university of pennsylvania
jim simons the most successful hedge
fund manager in the world and has given
a lot
like we're too tied to what doesn't work
if you think about string theory string
theory mopped up most of the best minds
during our time
and it doesn't work
and i don't when i say it doesn't work i
don't mean that we didn't learn anything
from it it wasn't inspiring i don't mean
that we should throw away the ideas i
don't mean that it won't eventually
um be part of something but it doesn't
work to find the theories we need and if
you can't say that which is terrifying i
mean you know
who am i to say that ed whitton doesn't
know what he's doing but edwin as a
leader of the field as opposed to a
researcher
took way too many resources in one
particular direction wasn't able to make
his bid
and right now
those very wealthy people
need to save this field and they need to
build fu money into the field so that
individuals don't have to knuckle under
brian here's my problem
i don't want to keep saying this and
most of what i do
i don't like which is correcting people
gu is doing fine it is
being listened to i'm in constructive
conversations i want to
i want to speed it up
i want to have conversations that i need
to be having we need to be having
conferences we need to be
you know having multiple i don't want to
take all the resources that were in
strings and become the same thing for gu
i want us to spread out get active get
excited and
it's time to save everybody else because
they can't save themselves everyone else
is frozen in place
turning on the news to find out whether
or not they've got a new virus or a
nuclear threat from eastern europe it's
crazy
um so when we look at you know these
these challenges i think you know as
nima said in an interview i read
recently that you know it's sort of
hardwired into physicist
dna to be reductionist uh i wonder if
you could have you know one piece of
data one datum
shall we say um what would be most
dispositive you know for any theory not
just to you but what would be sort of
the um the the
the key you know piece of data that
could be crucial and discriminating
between
the possibilities between all these
different models is there such a thing
yeah
there are particles
i can tell you what particles i think
are left to find
uh in terms of their signatures and it's
funny people always say well what mass
what energy which is like the one bit
that you'd
need quantum field theory to do because
you have to compute the radiative
corrections and there are a bunch of
things i don't know how to do yet and
maybe i can get there at age 56 maybe i
can't
um
but there are certainly particle
predictions that come out of gu that
would immediately say okay well he told
us all these you know they're they're in
that draft right
um
but that's the dumb version of it the
smart version of it is totally different
it's not a question about oh theory and
experiment in the scientific method it's
like
look at what is it 26 27 28 parameters
free parameters in the standard model
that's the ugliness
that no one wants to deal with who's
gotten involved in geometric physics
they don't want to take on three
generations with a ckm matrix with
random entries and a pmns matrix and
higgs couplings that determine the shape
of the mexican hat potential all that
stuff is artificial
what gu what i'm starting to do with gu
is to say oh i i see you didn't get why
i'm claiming there are three generations
that are observed inside of this
geometry you didn't understand why i'm
i'm claiming the higgs field makes sense
as opposed to as an artificial get out
of jail free card for the for the mass
generation
and
the real question is
do you not understand that the key issue
is naturality what we have is a workable
theory that is extremely unnatural it's
in a natural language there are natural
components the yang mills component is
very natural the deroc component is very
natural the internal quantum number is
incredibly unnatural the higgs potential
incredibly unnatural the number of
generations incredibly unnatural the
chirality knowing left from right
incredibly unnatural what gu offers is a
huge number of explanations of why this
unnatural structure is not only natural
but gorgeous
very interesting so in the last couple
of minutes that we have left um well you
mentioned you're going to some bitcoin
conference uh has that uh has your
thinking evolved on bitcoin
fixing this where this could be anything
from
uh any nuclei
i love those guys i know you guys one of
the reasons is that we fought
we went through this whole sort of
interpersonal drama stupidity
then they got kicked in the teeth when
they're pre the price of bitcoin
relative to fiat went down
and they realized that i wasn't their
enemy i was their friend i mean i'm not
i'm not one of them i'm not putting on
the laser eyes all that kind of stuff
but
i want them to be the big dogs at least
they're excited about life they're
excited about something that's new
and a lot of them have made money
and sooner or later you know one of the
things i took this guy robert breedlove
is one of the big bitcoin guys uh to the
university of chicago i wanted to show
him
what happens when you look at academic
economics uh from the point of view of a
different academic subject anytime these
guys want to they can start endowing
chairs and universities
to make sure that professors are present
who can say no you know it's interesting
like why is nobody endowing an
anti-wokeness chair people are bitching
about wokeness
but you could actually use money
to stop the persecution of scientists
inside of universities by their woke
colleagues from the humanities
um well you typically can't you know you
as a donor you know determine who gets a
particular job and yeah i can imagine a
lot of people's amount with money at a
university in fact some of the most
disreputable people in the world have
tried to launder their reputations by
contributing to universities i can think
of a particular center at a particular
university now that you could yeah yeah
um not i wasn't thinking about jeff
epstein in the media lab but thank you
for asking the the the um
what i'm trying to say is
we're acting powerless and we're acting
like we have an infinite amount of time
and we don't and what
what we need is we need a tiny number of
the world's smartest richest people
to wake up and recognize you're all
going to die and you're not going to be
able to take that with you you could at
least figure out
how to maybe save all of humanity in
your descendants because there's a huge
thank you
uh for whoever it is that actually steps
up to the plate i don't know what
they're doing we we we've produced the
wrong elite for sure
well sir in the remaining few minutes i
want to open the floor to
questions from you no i want to ask you
uh what you're excited about not to be
you know pollyannish about it we could
talk a lot about
let's let's phrase it like this is it
okay for me to ask you
uh you know kind of
coping strategies
what what are you doing to oh take care
of yourself i'm really excited strangely
about non-standard blues progressions so
i've been working with stormy monday
let's go get stoned um
the
song drown in my own tears
train kept it rolling all night long and
trying to understand why non-standard
blues progressions are so brilliant why
the brain doesn't really notice
how ingenious they are so that's been
something i've been super excited about
i just got a new spark
mini amplifier from positive grid they
sent me
so now i can walk around with my
electric guitar carrying a tiny amp with
huge sound which is greatly fun i'm
spending a tremendous amount of time
with your colleague and my son
zev who is on fire about history
philosophy
linguistics
physics
differential geometry and just to see
life through the 16 year old eyes
he's kicking my ass in all sorts of
things
it's just one of the great feelings
watching my daughter grow and trying to
think about
my golden retriever and my wife after
the kids have gone
and you know dreaming about uh travel
and maybe getting back to hindi and
russian and turkish and languages that i
love
so i'm still very much invested in
you know food song friends music
it's the desire to save all these things
that leads to the heaviness it's like i
love i love what we have so much and i
want to share it
and i don't
i don't know how to say i can't watch
everything i care about being balanced
on a pole
um with a cat
in a hat you know
keeping it on its nose it's just like
i end up as the fish because i care
about all of the things that are at risk
yeah it's true as they say you know if i
have committed one crime it's that i
love too much and obviously this
this is all we have i'm convinced
forever but uh but maybe maybe avi and
the galileo project and
other technologies will prove us wrong
but but for now i want to thank you i
want to wish you a happy spring happy
april fool's day solemn holiday observed
with many many different uh traditions
around the world fireworks let me just
say something before you let me go it's
been great watching uh you grow your
channel grow your presence
and take on all the stuff
you know with the dad jokes uh
as the adult in the room and uh thank
you for also bringing the perspective of
the experimentalist
um i think that you know you say this
and we don't hear you enough and you say
isn't it interesting that we keep
talking to the
the theorists uh in physics who sort of
scratch that itch when we don't believe
in god what is this place and
what are we and and what is the cosmos
in the universe and i do think that i'm
going to be looking for what you're up
to with the the telescopes uh in chile
uh anything you you're telling me about
what's going on at the south pole
cosmic inflation
the new james webb telescope and i think
focusing us
more on experimental physics physics is
something that is going to be part of
what comes next and i think it's an
absolutely important thing that we start
balancing some of the madness of
theoretical physics with some of the
practicality of the people who actually
prove that these things are true real
and have consequence so thanks
i appreciate that and from what i'm
looking forward to it's really teaching
teaching is a kind of a gift to the
future to your future self the future of
humanity i'm really enjoying it more
than i ever did and that's you know kind
of all these weird things like being on
a commercial airliner you know
like i enjoy it
it's weird to say but especially being
back with my students and teaching in
person there's no replacement and i'm
more bullish you know if you ask me
during kovid when we were talking about
the academic hunger games two years ago
for the first time on this channel we
rolled out that little uh le jar domain
or what is it called portmandu uh i i
wouldn't have thought that academia
could really survive and uh and yet i i
think i think it will because of there's
some richness that's irreducible in the
uh and the beautiful world of academia
that involves people convening to
discuss ideas and it still happens and
i'm still
delighted and honored to have people
like you to share it with so we have the
greatest diversity equity and inclusion
program on earth and it's called passion
and merit and it's open to one and all
absolutely well thank you my brother and
uh it's good to see you good to see you
too be well brian we'll catch up again
soon
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
well i hope you liked that interview
that i did with friend of the show eric
weinstein uh if you're interested in
seeing more with eric leave a comment
below and i'll
just be sure to bring it up with him on
our next conversation we hope to have
these quarterly
also coming up don't forget we've got
walter isaacson ed young
and uh we have phil goff coming on the
show to talk about consciousness
down to the level of electronic
consciousness are electrons conscious
and if you enjoyed this conversation
with eric please click here for the
special eric weinstein edition playlist
on the into the impossible podcast click
here don't forget to subscribe
[Music]
that's
you